[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du coup ça va pas changer le départ
quand j'étais petit
je voulais devenir tintin non pas pour
son côté héroïque ou justiciers mais
pour son audace et son côté et grand
voyageur avant même de savoir lire je
dévorais les bandes dessinées de tintin
et milou ensemble ces formidables ils
vont aux quatre coins de la planète ils
vont en egypte ils vont en afrique
aux etats unis ils vont même sur la lune
et j'étais fasciné enfants par ces
lointaines contrées ces différentes
cultures ces différentes langues et moi
donc j'ai grandi avec
avec ce héros tintin et dès que j'ai pu
mettre sur pied mais propre aventure eh
bien je les fais et aujourd'hui j'ai 26
ans et je pars moi-même à l' aventure je
pars faire des expéditions aux quatre
coins de la planète je mène des
expéditions en 4l donc à direct la vélo
à moto mais aussi à pied et ce qui
m'anime le plus dans mes aventures ce
sont les expéditions à caractère
géographique c'est à dire des
expéditions dans lesquels je vais aller
traverser une chaîne de montagnes ou un
océan traverser un désert ou descendre
le cours d'un fleuve
j'en retire des histoires que je partage
en documentaire en livres mais aussi en
conférence est en article aujourd'hui
j'ai 26 ans et je suis fraîchement
diplômé de sciences po et j'aurais pu me
diriger vers une toute autre carrière
mais j'ai fait le choix de devenir
aventurier et ce soir j'aimerais
justement prendre le temps de vous
expliquer ce qui moi m'a nîmes et me
pousse à essayer de vivre une vie
audacieuse alors qu' ici dans cette
salle a déjà fait plus de 25 kilomètres
à vélo d'affilée il ya une bonne partie
d'entre eux 25e et à vélo je précise
c'est pas uniquement la chercher son
pain ou ses enfants à l'école c'est
véritablement un passé une heure une
heure et demie en selle un gars comme
une bonne partie d'entre vous est bien
tel que vous voyez en haut de ce col en
roumanie je n'avais pas plus
d'entraînements que vous puisque après
mon bac j'ai décidé de partir seul
traversé une partie de l'europe de l'est
à vélo de budapest en hongrie jusqu'à
istanbul en turquie sans avoir plus
d'entraînements que vous puisque n'avait
jamais fait plus de 25 km d'attila duo
est en fait j'avais été inspiré par le
frère d'une amie qui avait fait un tour
du monde à vélo et j'étais fasciné par
les dires de me dire qu'il était
possible de traverser des dizaines de
pays
voir tout un continent à la force des
gens et donc j'ai suivi son voyage sur
son blog
d
toutes les semaines et quand il est
revenu en france je suis allé à son
arrivée et je vais demander quelques
semaines après s'il accepterait de me
prêter son vélo chose qu'il a faite et
je me suis moi-même lancer à l'aventuré
et je crois que c'est ça le plus
difficile c'est de faire le premier pas
c'est de se lancer et moi je n'étais pas
simple puisque c'était un voyage après
mais après mon bac tous mes amis étaient
ensemble en vacances en bretagne et moi
j'étais tout seul en hongrie sur mon
vélo à me demander un petit peu c'est
donc là jean marc est alors je vais
persévérer je continue de pédaler vers
vers la turquie
je faisais tous les jours un peu plus de
kilomètres que le jour précédent et je
m'étonnais parfois je dormais sous ma
tente parfois j'étais hébergé chez des
locaux et un beau jour je suis arrivée à
istanbul et je me souviens j'étais fier
j'étais heureux parce que j'avais
réalisé ce rêve et j'ai été fier en fait
d'avoir osé faire le premier pas me
lancer à vélo tout seul et en fait quand
je prends un peu de recul je crois que
c'est véritablement ça la difficulté
c'est de se convaincre qu'on va y aller
qu'on va le faire qu'on peut qu'on peut
se lancer et je pense qu'on se trouvera
toujours des excuses par exemple je n'ai
pas le temps j'ai pas l'argent je ne
suis pas assez sportif j'ai pas de vélo
moi à l'époque j'avais rien de tout ça
en revanche j'avais osé justement me
lancer et je pense que justement pour
passer le cap
si vous avez un projet qui vous tient à
coeur et bien moi ya un remède que
j'utilise et que je devais vous partager
c'est que quand vous avez un projet qui
est suffisamment mûr mais qui vous
manque le déclic pour y aller et bien
parlez-en à tout votre entourage
parlez-en à votre famille parlez-en à
vos amis à vos collègues et vous verrez
que le fait d'en parler
eh bien ça cristallise une forme
d'engagement vis-à-vis de vous même et
ça vous aide à vous lancer parce qu'on
ne vient pas aventurier ou chef
pâtissier entrepreneurs ou que sais-je
en claquant des doigts c'est
véritablement une démarche de se lancer
et pour moi c'est un peu ça être
audacieux c'est avoir le courage de se
lancer en 2013
j'ai choisi de mettre mes études entre
parenthèses pour faire un grand voyage
mon rêve de gosse c'était de faire un
tour du monde en partant de la france et
en faisant tout le tour de la terre pour
y revenir
et donc on a choisi avec mon ami
d'enfance de partir en 4l pendant onze
mois à travers 40 pays et quatre
continents
en mettant la 4l dans un container une
fois qu'on est arrivé au bout d'un
continent qu'on arrivait au bout de
l'asie qu'on arrivait au bout de
l'afrique et l'audace pour moi c'est ça
c'est c'est voir grand mais donc on
avait ce projet d'expédition
géographique mais je voulais du haut de
nos 21 ans avec nicolas ajouté instance
a ajouté une dimension solidaire à notre
aventure et donc on a fait le choix de
soutenir financièrement 150 micro
entrepreneurs l'idée c'était de leur
octroyer des micro-crédits avant notre
départ pour qu'ils puissent utiliser ces
sommes d'argent afin de démarrer une
activité ou d'en développer une
d'ailleurs génératrices de revenus et
notre mission c'est aller leur rendre
visite sur place
mais je me souviens bien bien à l'époque
qu'on avait 21 ans faisait pas du tout
les malins avec nicolas quand on est
arrivé avec nos plaquettes de démarchage
sous le bras voire des entreprises pour
nous aider à partir mais on est allé un
peu au culot et il y avait beaucoup de
gens qui croyaient pas en notre projet
je pense que les gens qui pensaient
véritablement con qu'on allait partir à
se compter sur les doigts d'une main et
je pense même que dans ces personnes là
les gens pensaient plutôt qu'on allait
faire un tour d'europe plutôt qu'un tour
du monde mais on a persévéré on a affiné
nos stratégies pour le démarchage parce
qu'on a fait beaucoup d'erreurs dès le
départ et ça a fini par marcher marcher
ça finit par tellement bien marché qu'on
en a fait un documentaire de 52 minutes
pour la télévision et un livre alors que
ni l'un ni l'autre n'était prévu au
départ
et quand je repense à tout ça il ya une
expression anglaise qui me vient à
l'esprit c'est fake it ain't you make it
et donc pour la traduction c'est fait
semblant jusqu'à ce que ça devienne vrai
fait semblant jusqu'à ce que ça devienne
une réalité et cette expression anglaise
pour moi elle est vraiment emblématique
de cette période nous ont préparé ce
tour du monde parce que ça paraissait un
peu fou de se dire que en septembre
nicolas mas on n'avait pas retourné sur
les bancs de l'université et qu'on
allait faire un tour du monde en 4l donc
l'audace pour moi c'est ça c'est la
capacité à voir grand l'audace c'est
aussi pour moi une histoire de
persévérance en 2017
j'ai participé au marathon des sables le
marathon des sables c'est une course à
pied en autonomie alimentaire dans le
désert du sahara au maroc qui consiste à
faire six marathons en six jours non là
c'est peut-être que je perds une grande
partie d'entre vous et que vous pensez
que je suis irrémédiablement est
définitivement totalement perdu mais
effectivement c'est une course qui est
un peu folle et qui m'apparaissent au
départ comme totalement inaccessible
parce que trop longue
trop difficile trop intense et en fait
après avoir couru quelques marathons et
bien l'homme est apparu tout de suite
comme plus plus accessible possible
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui me est
en fait ce qui m'intéressait dans le
marathon des sables ce n'est pas
tellement la performance parce que moi
je suis pas un athlète ni un un sportif
de haut niveau je me suis entraîné
raisonnablement en courant 20 à 30
kilomètres par semaine mais ce que
j'allais chercher dans le marathon des
sables
c'était vraiment l'expérience c'était
l'idée d'aller me dépasser d'aller
découvrir mes propres limites parce
qu'on ne repousse pas ses limites
on les découvre et c'est l'idée c'était
d'aller aller chercher là où je ne
serais pas allé chercher si je ne
m'étais pas lancé en premier lieu il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui me demandent
mais comment tu fais mathieu pour rester
motivé pour rester vaillante quand ça
devient compliqué parce qu'effectivement
les raisons ont d'abord donné sur une
telle course elles sont nombreuses
surtout quand on a dit clock à chaque
boîtier qu'on ne supporte plus la
température de 45 degrés ou qu'on a du
sable dans les chaussures et moi je me
raccroche à à une chose c'est que
l'inconfort la douleur sont les choses
sont temporaires et je me raccroche
aussi à l'effort que j'ai fourni pour
m'entraîner pour venir jusqu'ici les
raisons qui m'ont poussé à venir et
j'essaie de me convaincre que c'est un
mauvais moment à passer dans 39 jours je
prendrai un avion pour l'antarctique
l'antarctique c'est le continent le plus
froid le plus sec tu le plus venteux et
l altitude moyenne la plus élevée de la
planète je partirai faire une expédition
en solitaire sans assistance et en
autonomie totale de la côte du continent
antarctique jusqu'au pôle sud sans
assistance ça veut dire sans voile de
traction son chien de traîneau 100
véhicules à moteur et en autonomie
totale ça veut dire sans ravitaillement
de nourriture sont sur ma route alors
bien évidemment je me suis entraîné pour
cette aventure je me suis entraîné au
groenland au svalbard en norvège mais je
ne suis jamais allé en antarctique
jamais tirer un traîneau sur une telle
distance
je ne connais pas du tout la solitude
sur une telle durée mais je sens que
c'est peut-être ça en fait la définition
d'un projet audacieux c'est accepter
d'un auteur inconnu et apprendre à
l'aimer
pour partir faire ce genre d'aventuré
ils n'y font rien laisser au hasard
évidemment puisque je suis en solitaire
et en autonomie totale et donc il faut
avoir du matériel et donc je tirais dans
un grand traîneau tout ce dont j'ai
besoin pour survivre pendant 50 jours
donc une tente un sac de couchage en
tapis de sol quelques vêtements mais
aussi du des réchauds du combustible du
matériel électronique avec des
téléphones satellites et j'aurai tout le
matériel de sécurité et de survie en
double si jamais quelque chose devait
arriver donc j'aurai de réchauds en
double nos téléphones satellites de
boussole de gps parce qu'être audacieux
ou aventurier aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
être une tête brûlée
c'est véritablement calculer les risques
et les accepter ou les refuser
l'antarctique
j'en rêve depuis jeudi les aventures de
tintin et milou l'antarctique c'est pour
moi la mise en pratique de toutes les
expéditions mais j'ai pu mener tous les
enseignements que j'ai pu tirer du
marathon des sables mieux du vélo et
jamais j'aurais pu rêver du pôle sud
si je n'avais pas osé me lancer un jour
à vélo tout seul la vie est une aventure
audacieuse où elle n'est rien c'est une
citation d'helen keller qui est né à la
fin du 19e siècle aux états unis et qui
à l'âge de 18 mois est devenue sourde
aveugle et muette
c'est aussi la première personne
handicapée à obtenir un diplôme
universitaire elle est une véritable
icône en tout cas alors elle et elle est
emblématique de l'audace et ça montre
bien que l'audace s'est dessiné son
propre chemin alors pour ma part le
regret et mon moteur c'est à dire que je
suis plus animées par la peur du regret
que par la peur de l'échec c'est la peur
du regret qui me pousse à essayer de
vivre une vie audacieuse j'ai peur de me
dire plus tard j'aurais pu j'aurais dû
j'ai peur de passer à côté de ma vie
alors
je vis une vie audacieuse moi ça prend
la forme d' aventure ça prend la forme
d' aller au pôle sud mais c'est le barça
pourrait s'appliquer à tout un tas
d'autres domaines par exemple créer son
entreprise crée son association
apprendre une nouvelle langue apprendre
par exemple un instrument de musique
même se marier alors je terminerai par
une seule chose c'est que le temps c'est
l'ennemi de l'audace alors n'hésitez
plus faites vous confiance et fait de
votre vie une aventure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]